that Scottish accent is readable well is
it was it easy for you to the Scottish
accent being Irish it wasn't it wasn't
it was easy because the way the Scots
speak is quite similar to us so it was
basically just doing that and I could
speak in the same way but then it also
meant that you would just slip into your
own accent every now and again and all
right sound like Northern Irish are some
of them and they'd have to sound that
way even when I was speaking in French
which was weird did you have to learn
French for this yeah oh yeah you are
actually I meant to say Timothy it's
pronounced Timothy it's whatever you
like I thought it was timotei because of
the double easy yeah it's supposed to be
read but you could say Doug Alex like
guests like this but you are fluent in
the French yeah yes I'm let's say 97% I
always like you know give myself a
little stopgap because it's not perfect
okay no it's not perfect no effect you
also spoke Irish didn't you yeah so I'm
not fluent in Irish but I know little
words here and there and Eileen who's my
best mate she's in the film as well
she's the one in that clip who goes I'm
just a little cheeky grin to Adrian and
so we whenever we were like whenever we
were talking about someone basically I
would use Irish words so I wouldn't I'd
be like someone so I was driving me and
then use a parish where it and then one
of the sound guys came up to us one day
us thinking that we've gotten away with
it and he was like and that's you know
that I am Irish and I do understand
everything
we weren't talking about him we thought
we'd gone away with that
[Music]
you